[Music]
Ram Nash of Crosby stes naash young
helped you get into the studio to record
a demo like how do you hook up with him
yeah I'm really really really close with
his son um no kidding we one of my best
friends on the planet Earth Willie and
it's funny like he was this you know
rock and roll legend but also kind of my
my friend's dad and and they you know
like I would and so I was struggling and
kind of trying to this was like after
the cars flowers thing and I remember I
was hanging out with Willie a lot and
doing you know doing a bunch of nothing
just hanging out being kids and and he
kind of approached me and he's like hey
I heard you guys are you have new songs
and you want to go um demo them and
stuff like let me know if you want I'll
put you in you know for a little while
with some people I know and he put us
with some amazing people and I'll help
you make a demo and then that demo wound
up being the demo that got us our second
record deal so like he was hugely
integral in us getting a kind of a
second chance cuz we wouldn't have had
any money to make a demo for what what
we got signed off of so so that was huge
Graham I will always be eternally
thankful to and I also said to him I was
like look I'm going to give you a gold
record and I'm going to pay you back for
the studio time and he's like all right
whatever he didn't I don't think that he
cared about about any of that and I was
really that was kind of a proud moment
when I was able to um kind of repay him
and I did give him a gold record it was
cool what a magical story I mean I can't
even comprehend a life like that like
like Graham like Graham says to you hey
man let me let me help you out and well
he obviously recognized he had Talent if
he he like I don't think he just goes up
to all of his son's friends and starts
you know paying for their
demos maybe or or maybe not I mean he's
kind of a Pay It Forward kind of guy I
mean like he knew I was tight with this
kid and he maybe he like he's help this
kid out you know I've had success maybe
pay forward but who knows
why